spring has arrived in the deserts of
iraq's southern muthana province
april is a time when the sandy soil
should turn into grazing land
to allow livestock to gain weight ahead
of the scorching summer heat
instead camels must make do with
scattered patches of scruffy grass
climate change is eroding the sustenance
of these animals
spelling an existential crisis for the
nomadic tribes
who depend on them
there's no rain and the land is dry the
grass has turned into dessert
we have to sell some animals to buy food
for the rest
this is what life has become
during our visit clouds gathered in what
some hoped would be the first proper
downpour this year
but only a few drops trickled from the
sky
barely enough to wet the ground there
has been very little precipitation this
year
and when it does rain it's only for a
few minutes
which is not enough to transform this
desert
into pastures for a livestock to feed on
the wells that once sustained animals
and humans alike have long run dry
rather than migrating in sync with
mother nature
the bedouins buy water and truck it from
a nearby village
but how much longer can they keep going
before they're forced to abandon this
increasingly difficult way of life
rahihamis cannot imagine doing anything
else
he has no education no other source of
income
i never thought about leaving this life
and i never will until my animals leave
me
step by step the animals will disappear
the desert a long time ago today he has
come back to visit from a nearby town
there's no future here they only know
how to herd animals there's no education
there's no future for the bedouins maybe
in the end there won't be any left
out of saran's nine siblings only one
still lives a nomadic
life the rest have swapped tents for
brick
and mortar dwellings in the desert
hamlet of al-busaya
here saran found work in the local water
department
i prefer the desert but the kids have
gotten used to the town air conditioners
and phones
they go to school saran's five children
only know bedouin traditions from
stories passed down from their
grandfather
tales about humans living in harmony
with nature
about large animal herds moving freely
across borders
and feeding on seemingly endless green
pastures
it's a way of life that could soon be
just a memory
semana faulting al jazeera in iraq's
muthana province